[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday February 8th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
the battle for search Supremacy is
heating up for years if you wanted to
find things online you Googled it now
Microsoft is making a big push to
challenge that by integrating artificial
intelligence into its Bing search engine
Microsoft announced on Tuesday that it
was leaning on its multi-year
multi-billion dollar partnership with
startup open AI to incorporate a chat
bot similar to chat GPT that will be
front and center on Bing's homepage Wall
Street Journal senior personal Tech
columnist Joanna Stern sat down with
Microsoft CEO Satya Nadella to talk
about the new feature so the entire
point of chat GPD early on was to just
sort of show the power of the large
model and the conversational
intelligence we now have not only the
current information that you usually
expect from a search engine but you can
then have a full conversation around
that current information and all the
other information that came before the
Ws Jay's Joanna Stern is with us now to
talk about the new bang and her
conversation with Satya Nadella hi
Joanna how's Washington State you know
Rainey as you would expect but very
smart AI generated smart I'm also very
tired it's been a long couple of days
okay fair and in that couple of days you
got to try out this new version of bang
it can you tell us what it's like yeah
I've been talking to computers here in
Redmond that's what I've been doing I
did I have been testing out this new
version of Bing which if you've used
chat GPT won't seem so foreign to you
but it's better than chatgpt in a lot of
ways but to back up really Microsoft is
rethinking being entirely here the new
home page for Bing is going to have a
new box it's going to say ask me
anything and you can put in there your
usual search queries or you can really
talk to it like it's a chat bot right so
you can put in something like and this
is one of the queries I've been using
give me a recap of the 2023 Grammy
winners
so you'll get your usual list of links
and sites that have covered the Grammys
but you'll also start to see a little
bot typing away and trying to answer
those questions very similar to chat GPT
but there are two things that are
different here the first is that this is
based on real-time search data this is
based on what's in bing so it's current
right chat GPT stuck in 2021 on that
data set the second thing that it does
differently and this is something I
really think is great there are
citations so it says under each sentence
or every few sentences where that
information is from it's a clickable
link so if it's from CNN or The
Huffington Post or the Wall Street
Journal you can then click to those
links and read more about what this
chatbot Has Told You So that sounds like
it gets at the heart of one issue that
chat GPT comes up with a lot you know is
it incorrect or where did the
information come from one of the other
issues that people have had though with
chat GPT is the speed of it can you
explain kind of what that issue is and
how Microsoft plans to address it yeah
so there's two things on the speed the
first is that actually it takes these
really really super computers longer to
answer these questions because not only
is it trying to figure out what you just
said and so what is that question but
then it's trying to answer that like a
human right so that takes a lot of
computing power it also takes more
computing power to then feed in the
information for the answer this is a
huge model right so this is what takes a
lot of time
that is somewhat better here back to
that Grammy answer it took about a
minute for that full answer to show
itself on the page and that's quite a
bit of time right you might not want to
wait that long for something so you
could tell it like please keep your
answer shorter or there's going to be
certain places where you just want to
use regular search the second place that
there's been criticism of chat GPT and I
have this issue a lot I go to the site
and the servers are down or we're
running at capacity or something like
that Microsoft is trying to improve that
and I spoke to Mr Nadella about that and
here's what he said we're built out in
Azure some very robust infrastructure
for inference at scale that's what gives
us even the ability on day one to have
enough capacity to launch something like
this but at the same time we're going to
have uh to scale this carefully we don't
know what the traffic is going to look
like what the query patterns are going
to look like these are really early days
what about getting things wrong what
about mistakes that come up in these
answers Microsoft is not saying this is
going to be 100 percent accurate all the
time it says it's still learning this is
still based on early AI research and
early AI models this is not where we're
going to be in the future right this is
still a new area but they are going to
do some things to make it clearer that
this may not be something that is a
hundred percent right so it's been
programmed to use phrases like this is
not the definitive answer or it might
say this may be or this might be the
right answer Joanna you said you got to
play around with this new bang before
you spoke with Satya Nadella was it
helpful in your research before you did
the interview I did use it to compose
some questions for my interview as I got
the demo and I got to play around with
it before I got to sit down with him so
I said okay let's see what this wants me
to ask him truth was I had some of those
questions on my list they definitely
didn't sound as smart or as witty as me
I would say but they were good but one
of the cool things you can do is then
engage with it so I it wrote these
questions for Mr Nadella for me but then
I could say hey answer that question
number five in the voice of Mr Nadella
so for me as a journalist it's a good
way to practice interviews can anyone
use this new version of Bing yes anyone
can sign up to use this version of Bing
is that a good nuanced answer for you
there it was rolled out on Tuesday in a
limited preview and then you have to
sign up at bing.com and you can
hopefully get on the waiting list and
start using it but the biggest asterisk
right now is that you have to have the
Microsoft edge browser which is
available for Windows and Mac so you've
got to use it which by the way is the
browser I use and I think it is a very
good browser what did Nadella say about
competition with Google because there's
been a lot of speculation that this is
their big play to unseat Google and its
Supremacy in the search Market from
talking to Mr Nadella and other
Microsoft Executives over the last few
days you can really see how excited they
are about this technology and that they
really think they have something to
finally compete with Google right Google
holds 93 of the global search engine
market share that leaves Bing with so
much less really not even on the map and
so their hope here is just to capture a
little bit of that here's what Mr
Nadella had to say about that at the end
of the day we are grounded in the fact
that you know Google dominates this
space
and so I am thrilled for finally some
competition uh and uh so I I feel like a
new race is starting
with a complete new platform technology
uh and now it's a question of us and
them actually innovating releasing
things into the real world does
Microsoft plan to incorporate this AI
technology anywhere else I think the
question is where don't they plan to put
this AI technology is very clear they
want to put this in all of their
products it's already making its way
into Microsoft teams with transcripts
and summaries of meetings it is already
making it into some of their coding
products GitHub co-pilot is one of the
products they own Mr Nadella also
confirmed that they are going to put it
in Microsoft Office he didn't announce
timing on that but it is coming it's
very clear that this is how they want
Microsoft to be known now as this AI
leading company all right that was our
senior personal Tech columnist Joanna
Stern Joanna thanks for joining us
thanks guys and that's it for today's
Tech news briefing for more Tech stories
check out our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]